we got another deeply emotional reminder
of just how precious life is
Duane dog Chapman said his final
farewells to his wife Beth and only I
spoke to Duane before the memorial how
emotional will that service be well I've
got a man up okay do you see this bounty
is there a such thing as man enough in a
situation like this you're asking me
that I am a crybaby I would be crying
through the whole thing and I saw I
can't stop it I can't believe that she's
God this is not possible I want to wake
up from a dream just as Dawg predicted
he delivered an emotional eulogy at best
memorial in Colorado I've never felt
like this Saturday's PAC service was
open to the public and live stream more
than 1 million viewers have watched
online their two children together
Bonnie and Gary also gave tear-filled
speeches I'm just you know sad she's not
gonna see me graduate college and get
sworn in Hub I never imagined having to
write a speech about this sorry if I cry
as et reported their upcoming reality
show dogs Most Wanted will still air on
WGN America later this year dog says it
was best dying wish for them to be on TV
together one last time we're just gonna
have fun and love each other and laugh
all the way and when it ends it ends the
show did not kill her but she died for
it
I said honey you might have to do chemo
stuff she goes all it'll do is keep me
alive six months longer and I'm not
gonna do that because I want to be by
your side
[Music]